el acceso en Estados Unidos a la píldora
abortiva mifeprisstona pende de un hilo
un juez Federal en Texas resolvió
suspender su aprobación por la agencia
de medicamentos estadounidense la fda
respondiendo a la petición legal de un
grupo cristiano antiaborto retrasó la
entrada en vigor de la decisión durante
una semana hasta el viernes 14 de abril
para recibir apelaciones y el gobierno
de Joe biden ya aprovechó
[Música]
esta administración apoya a la fda y
está preparada para esta batalla legal
Seguiremos trabajando para proteger los
derechos reproductivos y asegurar que
las mujeres pueden tomar sus propias
decisiones sobre sus cuerpos sin
interferencia del gobierno pero la
mifepristona es protagonista de otra
batalla legal los fiscales de 17 estados
empezaron en Washington un proceso
separado para expandir el acceso al
fármaco el juez ordenó que mientras tome
una decisión el acceso al medicamento no
puede alterarse eso podría mantener la
mifepristona accesible al menos en estos
17 estados
sin embargo se espera que las
apelaciones lleven la discusión a la
Corte Suprema la misma corte que el año
pasado revocó el derecho al aborto en
Estados Unidos
Pero qué es la mifepristona esta
pastilla se usa en la mitad de los
abortos de Estados Unidos hasta las 10
semanas de gestación
inhibe la progesterona una hormona
necesaria para el desarrollo del
embarazo y se usa en combinación con el
misoprostol El fármaco que realmente
provoca el aborto para aliviar los
efectos secundarios y garantizar más
posibilidades de éxito en caso de que la
mifepristona deje de ser accesible los
embarazos todavía Se podrían interrumpir
solo con misoprostol sin embargo este
escenario Podría tener consecuencias sin
precedentes
pondría en jaque La autoridad de la fda
que aprobó la pastilla hace más de 20
años y podría empujar a miles de mujeres
al aborto quirúrgico un procedimiento
que tiene más riesgos para la salud